well good to see you your daughter multi
is one now she's one one 13 months now
that's exciting it's amazing how is it
y'all loving it yeah it's the oh my gosh
she's the most chill amazing baby has
the best personality laughing all day
super curious
um yeah but it's terrifying because she
bumps her head like five times a day she
only wants to play with wires phone
sockets yeah knives yeah she's like what
does this do yeah that's like constant
constantly like that oh my God I
remember that I'm so glad that's not my
face right now yeah oh my gosh I mean
there's other ones does it get worse it
gets different it's like but it's
awesome I love my daughter was curious
like that too and it's I mean she's
totally gonna give me gray hair but
she's also like super bold like she's
and I love that from a young age like
even when she was like one I could tell
I was like oh she's gonna she's gonna
have a very good sense of who she is and
like very bold and brave and that's what
I you'll love that I feel like she's
Brave she knows exactly what she wants
yeah but it's also going to give you
great hair yeah this is me too I think
it's starting Nick said that she um he
sings to her right yes I think that's so
adorable like even whenever like she was
in the womb right like that's adorable
what kind of music what Tunes when we we
were in I mean for those who don't know
um we had a really rough Journey with
malty and she was in the NICU for about
110 days
um and pretty much the whole third
trimester and
um Nick used to go in with his guitar
and I mean sing to her I played my
audiobook you know
or movies I couldn't compete I was like
you could sing and if you're not like
that yes
yes yeah but I mean I did she's the only
fan of my voice she like loves when I
sing the only person
[Music]
[Applause]